bonjour si vous regardez ceci cela signifie que
vous avez réussi les
essais de labyrinthe damn on greenie tout ce qui
vous est arrivé tout cela a été fait pour une
raison quel est cet endroit qui nous a mis
ici
nous ne savons pas bienvenue dans la clairière votre
les épreuves viennent juste de devenir ce qui se
passe là-bas
c'est le labyrinthe personne n'a jamais survécu à une
nuit dans le labyrinthe ce qui arrive à Thomas
vous ne vous en rendez peut-être pas compte mais vous êtes très
important et si nous étions envoyés ici pour
une raison vous devez être testé  pour
comprendre ce qui vous rend différent bientôt
et construit avec moi, je pense qu'il est temps que nous
découvrions ce que nous sommes vraiment contre
tout a commencé à changer au moment où
vous vous êtes présenté
les portes ne ferment pas tout le monde
plutôt souhaite ma vie là-bas que de
passer le  le reste ici, nous
pouvons sortir d'ici, nous sortons maintenant mais
nous mourons en essayant
Je pense qu'il est prudent de dire que les essais de labyrinthe
ont été un succès complet que le monde extérieur
attend,
alors avançons,
il est maintenant temps de commencer la phase deux
welc  venez à la brûlure